Jean Raymond le mieux a sauté à pieds
joint dans le défi pissenlit
durant le mois de mai pas de tente de
pelouse l'objectif aider les insectes
pollinisateurs comme les abeilles à
trouver de la nourriture
on sait que les abeilles ont de la
difficulté alors le petit peu qu'on peut
faire on le fait un peu à l'image du
mouvement nommé lancé en Grande-Bretagne
et qui prend un mois de mai sans
tondeuse
ce couple d'apiculteur a eu l'idée de
lancer le défi pissenlit en 2021 sans
pour autant se concentrer uniquement sur
le mois de mai pour offrir en fait cette
source de nectar et de pollen aux
insectes pollinisateurs qui en échange
assure la pollinisation de 35% de ce
qu'on mange des insectes vitaux mais
dont la population a fortement chuté au
Québec durant les dernières années en
raison notamment de la prolifération du
varois destructeur au point qu'en 2022
la pénurie d'abeille froulait les 60%
dans la province
tous les secteurs d'habitation ne se
prêtent toutefois pas à cette pratique
en raison de la présence de tiques dans
les secteurs plus humides et propice à
la maladie de Lyme dans les secteurs
boisés
justement de diminuer un peu les
l'humidité aux endroits où on circule
beaucoup et pour ceux qui le peuvent
comme Jean Raymond le mieux la clé pour
faire pousser ses pissenlits en paix
c'est de ne pas avoir peur du regard des
autres j'étais un peu gêné parce que les
voisins qu'est-ce que les voisins le
dire donc je m'étais gossé une pancarte
pour pour montrer que garantie pour les
abeilles c'est pas parce que je suis pas
sûr puis finalement le maintenant c'est
plus nécessaire tout le monde tout le
monde a compris c'était quoi l'idée ici
Daniel cadeau Radio-Canada Montréal